what is going on guys welcome to this
python course for network programming in
today's video you're going to learn
network programming principles in python
taught on four different projects so
we're going to do a mailing client
we're going to learn how to automate
mails we're going to learn how to do a
ddos script
so a little bit of penetration testing
there we're also going to build a
threaded port scanner
which is essentially just a port scanner
on steroids so it's going to scan
multiple ports at a second at the same
second
and we're also going to build a tcp chat
that allows you to chat with the server
and multiple clients connected to the
server at once so i hope you enjoy this
video and let's get right into it
now let's get started with the code the
first thing we need to do is we need to
import the smtp
library of python smtp is a protocol
that we're going to use to send mails
because what we need to do here is we
need to take our script and log
into an existing mailing account so make
sure you have one
you log into an existing mailing account
and then use the smtp protocol with your
python script
in order to send mails from that account
to other accounts so you cannot just
send mails directly from the python
script
you use the python script to log into
your existing mail account
and then use the smtp protocol to send
mails from there
um so this is what we're going to do and
for this we need to define a server
the server is defined by smtplib.smtp
and here you have to specify the smtp
server
and a port and the port we're going to
use is 25 for smtp
and the smtp server address is usually
something that you can find out by
googling so
you just type in smtp server gmail smtp
server yahoo whatever provider you're
using
so smtp.gmail.com for example is the one
for google
it's a very uh basic format actually you
always write smtp dot most of the time
it's just going to be
dot whatever your provider's domain is
in my case i'm using
a an austrian uh provider here where i'm
hosting my
website which is world4you.com so
smtp.world4you.com is the
address of my smtp server here we're off
the smtp server of my provider
and once we have that we're just going
to start it
to start the whole service here by
calling the ehlo command
so this is the function you need to call
to start the whole process and now the
next thing that we need to do is we need
to log
into the account so you have your smtp
server a gmail or whatever it is
and then you just log into your account
and to do that of course you need the
information first you need the email and
the password
and i would never recommend saving the
password clear text in your
um script because what you essentially
need to do is you need to say
server.login
and then you know you have your mail
here mail at mail.com whatever
and then your password here password123
whatever it is
uh you can do it like that if you want
if you're just using the script with a
crappy mail account that you don't need
just for experimentation you can do it
like that but i would not recommend it
what you should usually do is you should
save your
your password encrypted in a text file
then
load that text file decrypt it and then
use that password
for this tutorial i'm just going to save
the clear text password
or actually save the clear text password
already in a text file
and i'm going to read it here so that
you as a
viewer are not able to see it so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to see with
open i'm going to open a text file
stream uh with open password dot txt
in reading mode sf and we're going to
say
password equals f.read
so now i have the password that i saved
in this password txt file
i now have it in the script and i'm
going to say server
dot login and now you have to specify
your mail so whatever
maybe yours is alex gmail.com whatever
it is
in my case i created a separate email
for this tutorial so
mail testing at neural9.com
and the password is the one we just
loaded so this is how you log into your
server
into the smtp server into your mail
account and now we can start creating
the message
now before we can start creating the
mail message what we need to do is we
need to import some additional libraries
because
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a message a mail
consisting of multiple parts of
attachments of messages of headers
uh and for this we need to import some
additional libraries so let's start with
from
email import encoders which is something
that we're going to need
later on this video not not yet
and also let's say import not frozen set
from email
import mime text
which is the ordinary text that we're
going to use um
actually from email dot mime dot
text import mime text then from
email dot mime dot base
we're going to import mime base which is
what we're going to use for the
attachment and then
for the whole thing we're going to use
mime dot multi-part
import multi-part um
that's it and now we can start creating
the message using these libraries here
so the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to define the message
as
a my multi-part and we're going to
define the header and the header is
essentially consisting of a from to
and a subject so we're going to say
message equals or actually message
from equals because message can be
treated like a dictionary we can just
say okay message from
equals and here we're going to say
neural nine or your name whatever you
want you can put here
um all kind of creative stuff and we can
say
two and here you usually just specify
the target email
in my case i'm going to use a 10 minute
mail but i'm not going to use the 10
minute mail domain because the 10 minute
mail domain
for some reason it's not able to receive
attachments i tried at least when i was
experimenting with my script
i couldn't receive attachments there so
i'm going to use a german spam mail
provider which
is providing 10 minute mails and the
domain is called spammel.de so i'm going
to just say
mail testing at spamo
or actually this is probably not that
that intelligent because my mail is
already mail testing let's say
uh test mails at spammel.de
you can use a different one you can also
use your existing email a real email
i'm just going to use a spam mail for
this video
then we're also going to say subject
equals
um whatever you want it to be
just a test this is essentially what
you're going to see
once you receive the mail in the subject
and
uh that's essentially it now you can
specify a text for your message and i
usually do this in a file so
we're going to create a new text file
here we're going to say message.txt
and here we're going to just write our
mail message hello world
this is a mail sent with
python uh
subscribe to neural nine
always got to do this as we're used to
it
to it already from the other videos kind
regards
uh neural nine there you go
then you have the message here and what
you do then is you just load the message
the same way you loaded the password if
you loaded it
so with open message
dot txt in reading mode s
f we're going to say message
equals f dot read that's essentially it
and this is something that you just need
to attach to the message
object here so message.attach
which is not the attachment we're going
to add the attachment later on so we are
not adding
oh sorry not text.txt you're not adding
the
um txt file to the mail you're adding it
as a text and we're later on also going
to add an image
as an attachment so what you need to do
now is you need to
attach mime text
and you're just going to pass the
message here
and you're going to attach it as plain
text
so this is how you add a header and a
text to your message object
now one more thing that want to do
before we send the actual message is you
want to attach an image to it so in this
case i downloaded the royalty free image
from
pixabay uh you can also use google
images if you're just using it for your
personal experimentation you're not
going to get sued for that
so i just picked this coding.jpg file
from pixabay because i'm doing a video
and i shouldn't
be using copyrighted images here um
however
you get this image put it into the same
directory and then you specify the file
name
file name in this case coding.jpg or
essentially the file path if it's
somewhere else you can also specify the
whole path
and then we're going to open up
attachment equals open
we're just going to open a file stream
of this file name
and now we're going to open it in
reading binary so we're not going or
reading bytes
we're not going to open it up in reading
text mode but in reading byte
mode because we're using um
we're working with image data here not
with text data anymore
uh so the next thing is we're going to
create a payload object so we're going
to say p
equals and now we're going to use this
mime
base object so we're going to say
minebase
and here we're just going to start a
so-called
don't ask me what it stands for it's a
application and then it's called an
oc t e t stream
which is essentially the scene uh the
stream that we're going to use to
uh process this image data here and then
we're going to set the payload of this
payload to attachment to the file stream
dot read or actually
like that attachment.read i'm not sure
if we even need those
parentheses here i don't think so
so attachment.read and this is what you
set
as the payload you just read the content
of this attachment
with reading byte modes uh and
you set the payload now the next thing
you want to do is you're now going to
use the encoders
so we're going to say encoders and code
base64 so we're going to encode
the image data that we just read and
that we set as a payload
uh we're going to encode p and then
we're going to add a header to p so
we're going to say
p dot add header content
disposition and we're going to use an f
string here to say
application or attachment sorry
attachment
semicolon and then file name and now of
course we add the file name here
which is just file name and this is how
you add the attachment of course now
the payload the attachment itself has to
be attached to the message
so i'm going to say message.attach
yeah message.attach p and that's how you
add
the actual payload to the message now
the last thing we need to do is we need
to say text
equals message dot
um as string so we finally get the whole
thing as a string
and this string can then be sent by the
server so we're going to say server dot
send mail and we're going to send it
from
mail testing
at neural nine dot com
to our target what was it test males
test male start
and we're going to send the message
which is the text
now this is the whole script and we're
now going to test it
so now what i did is i created a spam
mail on spammel.de it's german don't get
confused by that
but you can also use any other spam mail
provider
or you can just use a real mail as a
target um
in this case i just didn't want to use
or show any of my personal emails so i
use this
spam test mails at spamo.te and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
run our script so we're going to say run
and if we didn't make
any mistakes this should now send the
email without any errors
wow we didn't get an exception i'm
surprised to be honest
and now let's wait for it and see if we
get something here and
you get it here just a test hello world
this is a male scent with python
subscribe to neural nine kind regards
neural nine you can also see that
uh avas or avest was checking this mail
so if you don't want this message to
appear just if you're using the same
anti-virus software just turn it off
and you can also see that there is an
attachment in here coding.jpg
and if i download it you can see that
it's the exact image that we wanted to
send
so it worked the script worked you have
neural nine at
an unknown i don't know if we have the
male header here somewhere as well
but if you're using a normal mail
account this should appear as
neural nine as uh or your mail not
neural nine
as in this case mail testing at neural
nine dot com
uh in this case it says neural nine at
unknown i don't know why it does that
but essentially it works the subject is
here the text is here as a normal text
and
then we also have the attachment so it
worked perfectly fine
and that's basically it
we're going to code a distributed denial
of service script which is basically
a script that overloads a website with
requests
so that this website is not able to
offer its service anymore because you're
overloading its
capacities basically so before we get
into the code let's talk a little bit
about how ddos basically works um
you have one attacker and this attacker
chooses a target for example the server
of a shop
or off a newspaper or something and says
okay i want to take this side down so
what do i do i send 5000
or 10 000 or 50 000 requests per second
so that the server will be overloaded
the capacities are not
enough to handle all these requests and
as an effect of that
if a normal user wants to connect to
that website it's also not possible
because you're getting
50 000 uh requests per second so if i as
a normal user
as a customer want to visit that website
i'm not
going to be able to do that because the
hacker is already or actually ddos is
not hacking but
the attacker is actually flooding the
server with
a request so i cannot visit the site as
well now of course you can counteract
this by blocking the ip address of the
one who's sending all these requests
or actually blocking all the ap
addressed addresses
except for your own and then you know do
some stuff in the back end or something
but usually that is how it works you
have an attacker and this attacker
chooses to take down a website by
flooding it with requests
now first of all before we get further
into this video i want to mention that
ddos is highly illegal so if you do it
do it on your own server do it off the
server onto the server of someone you
know
that gives you permission to do it don't
just go ahead
and ddos amazon or any other web page
because you can get sued and you can't
get imprisoned for that so i am not
responsible for what you do
with this knowledge here it's purely
educational i'm not encouraging you to
attack certain websites or something so
this is just so that you understand how
it works
how to implement it with python and then
you can penetration test your own
systems with it
but don't go ahead and you know attack
some strangers
or some websites of other people
having said that let's talk about how
this is done
when you're attacking bigger targets
because in year 2010 i think
anonymous took down paypal because of
the whole julian assange affair
but of course the problem is that paypal
is quite a big service
and if you want to take down paypal and
of course you shouldn't do it but i'm
just saying
if you want to take down a big target
like paypal you cannot just go ahead on
your own and
run a script what you do is you use a
so-called botnet so you in fact other
computers
these people don't know anything about
it but you just go ahead and you
uh in fact your computer for example my
computer
just people that don't know what's
happening and you're basically
having them as your zombie army it's not
about harming these people so you're not
infecting their computers with
a virus deleting their file encrypting
their files
uh or you know getting information from
them like passwords or something
you're just using them as your army so
you're using them as your soldiers
so uh they will probably not uh
recognize that you're even
uh taking control of them because you
know you're not doing anything with them
unless you want to attack a target so if
you have let's say 50 000 computers in
your botnet
you have 50 000 people uh for example
grandmas or
people that don't know anything about
coding anything about
networking about hacking they're just
using their computers but when you say
start
they start executing the same script as
you are so you're basically saying okay
i want to hack paypal
uh i use my botnet all these 50 000
computers are going to run this script
right now and everyone is flooding
paypal with 50 000
uh requests per second and
50 000 times 50 000 is a pretty big
number
and of course what happens in addition
to that is this is just
one attacker with one botnet and uh
in the attack on paypal you had multiple
attackers with their
own botnets uh ddosing people so this is
how
they took down people and again i'm not
recommending you to do that i just want
you to know how this happens
and i want you to understand how this
works so that you can maybe
penetration test your own systems with
it or even uh
take some counteractions uh security
measures based on that knowledge
but that is basically how ddosing works
so now let us get started with the
coding and the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to import
threading and we're going to import
socket
uh socket because we're going to use it
to connect and threading because we're
going to run multiple threads now one
more thing that i need to mention here
is
python is maybe not the best language to
do this because
python doesn't support real
multi-threading so
uh if you're doing multi-threading in
python it's not actual multi-threading
it's
simulated multi-threading so you're
basically switching between the tasks
as fast as possible but it's not actual
multi-threading so you might want to use
a different language for that but it
still works uh since
it's sending a lot of requests at the
same time just so that you know what's
happening in the
behind behind the scenes basically so
what we need here first
is we need a target and this target is
usually an ip address but it can also be
a um a domain name because the domain
name
can be resolved into an ip address uh
but what i'm going to do here i'm going
to just
ddos my own router and i recommend you
to do the same unless you have a website
on your own so if you have i don't know
uh if your name is john stevenson or
something and you have johnstevenson.com
please don't ddosjohnstevenson.com if it
exists
but if this is your web page go ahead
and ddos that webpage
but um other than that just uh keep it
in your own network so ddos your router
ddos your own laptop
run a run an apache server onto your own
system and then ddos that if you want
but don't go ahead and ddos some other
websites it's highly legal
again so the ip of my router
my inside ip is 10.0.0.138
and if you want to know what your ip is
you can just go ahead and say cmd okay
and then you say
ipconfig and you're going to see
uh wireless lan adapter since i'm using
wireless lan here
um you can see your own ip this is the
ipv4 address which
is the one that you're using in your own
network so this is not a public ip
address otherwise i wouldn't be showing
you that
this is just in my network at home this
is my ip address
and the default gateway is my router so
this is the ip of it
um so if you want to ddos your own
router you can just go ahead and say
uh ddos this ip address here uh it will
be probably different in your system
or in your network uh however depending
on the port that we're ddosing
different things can happen so if i ddos
on port 22
i'm ddosing the ssh service so the
command line service the secure shell
service
um and the website will still work if i
ddos
port 80 i will lead off the http port so
the web interface
might be down so depending on which
service i'm going to take down or i want
to take down
i'm going to attack a different port in
this video we're going to attack
http so i'm going to say port equals 80
and what we can also do here is we can
specify a fake ip
for the header however please don't
think that you're anonymous just
because you specify a fake ip in the
header
you of course need to use um
anonymization tools so you cannot just
go ahead and change the http header
and then think that you cannot be
recognized as a hacker
but still it's a nice extra that you can
add to your script so you can say fake
ip equals and then you just choose an ip
whatever it is
um let's just choose 182.
2032 and that's just
one sample ip that you can have and
these are
the the things that you need in order to
specify the target and also add your own
fake information into the header
so now we're going to define the actual
attack method and this method doesn't
look like an attack method because it's
basically just an
endless loop running uh
a socket connection so what we do is we
say def
attack we need to define a method here
so that we can later on refer to that
method in the threads
and what we do is we say while true
basically an endless loop and then we
say as
equals socket dot socket
socket dot af inet
which is basically just creating a new
socket an internet socket and then
specifying the protocol which is tcp so
stock stream and when we've done that we
just
say s dot connect to the target on the
port we need to pass a tuple here
um and that's basically it now we have
to send
the header and for this i'm going to
copy the two lines from
the website just because i don't want to
remember the whole
format here as i said you can find the
text based version on neural nine dot
com so if you
want you can just you know copy it from
the website or
type it in manually we just say get
slashed and we enter the target
then we say specify the http version
encode the whole thing and send it to
the target on the specific port
then we also say host enter the fake ip
address
encode it and send it to target and port
and after that we just close the
connection that's basically the whole
attack method
it's just uh constantly connecting
sending
closing connecting sending closing over
and over again
uh but of course this would not be
enough we need to run this in multiple
threads so what we do is we basically
say
uh for i in range
how many threads do you want to run you
can say 500 for example or
50 or 5000 uh what we do is we say
threat equals threading dot threat
and we basically specify target but this
time this is not the ip target but the
target function
and this is attack and then we say
threat
dot start and that's actually it
that's actually the whole script we just
have an attack method we have the
uh 500 threads that run this attack
method
uh when we run this the connections will
be made but of course we won't see
anything
if you want to see how many connections
have been made all uh
all the time of course this will slow
down the script so printing the
connections
uh printing the amount of connections
already uh
done will slow down the script so what
we can do
uh is we could say already
uh i don't know attacked or okay not
attacked
already connected stupid name i know
let's say zero what we do then
is when we close the connection we just
say okay global
so that we can access this already
connected variable
global already connected and then we say
already connected plus equals one and
i think that's actually it let me take a
look oh of course we need to print it
sorry
and then we can just print already
connected
um yeah then we can run it
and see what happens you can see
immediately
we have around 500 of course it's way
faster if we don't print all the numbers
so what we can do is we can say
uh if already connected
modulus 500 equals zero which basically
means
every 500 uh
connections you can print it what we do
is we just say print already connected
so it will only print every 500
connections still or
did i make a mistake here oh no actually
it's that slow
so it's probably not a good script at
all but
still it works um or maybe it's that
slow because i'm
asking all the time i don't know
however basically this is how you do it
you define a method that
sends a connection in an endless loop
and then what you do is you basically
run multiple threads at the same time
attacking then you have
bots or a botnet with computers that all
run the script at the same time
and then maybe you also have multiple
attackers and in the end you take down a
service like that
uh of course you can again specify
different ports then
this part here doesn't make a lot of
sense but you can also
uh try to take down the ssh server
or other services whatever but this is
how you basically do it you define a
method
run multiple threads and then you take
down a system
so that's it for today's video again
this episode was purely educational so
first of all
the script is not optimal you would not
use it for an actual ddos attack it's
not a good script you wouldn't use it um
it's just so that you
can get an understanding of how
something like this could be done
but no one would ever use this python
script for a ddos attack
first of all because it's slow second of
all because it's not really heavy
you're not sending a lot of data um
but it's just to see how you could do
this in python
uh second of all if you're using ddos
this script or any other script
keep in mind it's illegal use it on your
own systems i mentioned it two times
before
but it's very important and you
shouldn't you know
do any harm with these scripts
we're going to create a port scanner in
python which is going to allow us to
find open ports in
servers computers printers basically any
kind of host
and we're going to use multi-threading
to make this port scanner as fast as
possible so we're going to run multiple
threads
so that we can scan hundreds of ports
per second
now before we start with the video let
me tell you that you can find
a text based version of this tutorial at
neural nine dot com which is a blog post
and there you'll also be able to copy
the code if you want so
if you're interested in that check that
out you'll find a link into the
description
and you can also check out the other
blog posts about machine learning
programming and so on this page if
you're interested in them
so let's get to port scanning now first
of all
why scan ports why are we interested in
open ports
we're interested in open ports because
an open port especially an
unnecessarily open port might be a
security gap
and we always want to find security gaps
either in our own networks
to make sure that our network is secure
enough or if we have
bad intentions and we are hacking we
want to find
open ports in networks of other people
now notice that port scanning is illegal
even though it's not a hacking attack in
and of itself it's an
illegal act so don't scan networks that
you don't have any permission for
only scan your own network your own
computers your own servers
don't do this for exploitation purposes
so i've warned you i don't take any
responsibility for what you're doing
this
content here is purely educational so if
you use it for something bad
it's your fault and i do not advise it
now let's get into port scanning itself
how does port scanning work or how are
we going to scan ports
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use sockets
um to connect to a certain target to to
connect to a certain server
or ip address at a specific port if the
connection succeeds we're going to say
this
port is open if it does not succeed
we're going to say disport is closed
and to do that we're going to implement
a port scan method so let's start with
that we're going to import the socket
module
and we're going to say uh def port
scan and we're going to pass a port here
now to scan a port as we said
we have to try to connect so what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
socket first
uh socket dot socket
um socket again
dot af e-net or inet
which stands for internet basically
we're just saying okay this socket is an
internet socket and not a unix socket
and the second parameter is socket
dot sock stream sorry
sock stream which basically just says
that we are using
tcp instead of udp now that we have
created a socket what we're going to do
is we're going to connect
um and before we can connect we have to
define where we're going to connect to
because
when we use the connect method we have
to
pass a tuple and the first part of the
tuple is
the ip address which would be our target
and the second one the second parameter
here is
the port so the port is actually the
parameter of this
function so we can just pass it but the
target we have to define a target and as
i said
use your own computers use your own
servers or
servers that you are permitted to use so
uh do whatever you want but don't scan
the network or someone else that you
don't have permission to
so basically just pick a device from
your home
now in my case i'm going to pick my
router which has the ip address
10.0.0.138
and it's my default gateway if you don't
know
what ip address to choose you can always
pick localhost localhost
would be 127.0.0.1
this would be your own machine that
you're operating on right now so if you
don't know
what to scan just scan your own computer
that you're working on right now
now what we're doing here is we're
saying connect
to the target which is our ip address
here and we're saying connect on this
particular port
now if we don't get any errors or any
exceptions up until now
the connection succeeded and we can
return
true this means our port scan was
successful
or basically the port scan was always
successful but our
port is open so we found an open port
the connection was successful
if this is not the case so if we get
some exception some error
we're going to just return false
now with this method here already we can
scan ports so i can just say
print port scan
80 should be open because it's http
and as you can see i get true now if i
check for another port maybe 98
hopefully it's closed
yeah it's close so i get false um so
whenever i get
i cannot connect to a port i return
false and every time i can connect to a
port i return true
so this is how this method works and we
could go ahead now and just write a for
loop
for port in range and then
just define a range of ports for example
from 1 to
124 which would actually just scan up
until 123. these are the so-called
standardized ports
that are reserved for http ftp
uh and ssh telnet and so on so we're
going to say
scan all of these ports and every time i
get a result which is either true and
false so
board scan
port so we're scanning the port that we
have right now in the loop
and then we say if the result we can
just say if results since it's a boolean
so if true if false you know if the
result is true
we say print port whatever
is open and we can format
in the port number and otherwise we just
print
port whatever is closed
format port so when we run this you will
see
that it starts checking for all the
ports like port 1 is closed
port 2 is closed and so on and it
continues to do that in a very very slow
pace as you can see we barely make any
progress it's very very
slow now to change that
what we can do is we can introduce
multi-threading as i said
and to do this we cannot just start 30
threads because it would be very
inefficient to just run multiple threads
because if we just run multiple threads
what happens is we
can or the possibility is there that we
check the same port number twice
so to make this as efficient as possible
we're going to use
so called cues so we're going to import
two more libraries here first of all
import threading because we need we need
the threats
and also from q import
q with a capital q so a cube basically
is like a connect a collection or like a
sequence like a list maybe
where we have all kinds of elements and
every time that we get an element
from this list it's no longer in the
list so uh we're basically cueing the
elements
in this case we're queuing the port
numbers and
i can say i have all the ports numbers
uh port numbers from one to one thousand
and every time i get one uh the whole
list the whole sequence
shifts and i can get a new one well
we'll see how this works in a second
but first of all let's remove this loop
and
start by defining an empty queue here
that we're going to fill up later on so
q
equals q
and i'm also going to create an empty
list with the o
for the open ports actually this is the
list where at the end we'll add all the
open ports so that we can see which
ports are open in an uh final report
now what we're going to do now is we're
going to fill up this queue
and to do this you can choose whatever
method you want you can just fill
uh i don't know 10 000 porch numbers
into it you can uh
fill just a list of numbers into it you
can write your own method if you want
what we're going to do right now is
we're going to define a method fill
fill queue and we're going to
uh say from port
and to port so we're going to define a
range
you can also pass a list it doesn't
matter
basically you're just saying or let's
let's do a list
actually it's i think it's more it's
better let's say
port list we're going to pass
a port list and what we're going to do
is very simple we're just saying
4 port in port list
we are going to
put in every port into the queue
now the queue operates by the first in
first out
system so the port that enters the list
first is the first to get scanned so
i'll start putting in one two three and
these are the ports that will be scanned
first so
i'm basically just taking the list that
we can pass later on
and i'm filling this list into the queue
now the next step is to define a
so-called worker method because the
worker method
is the actual function or method
which our threads are going to be using
so
when we run a thread we want it to
execute this function and
this will be the port scan actually so
we're going to save for every thread
every thread is going to execute this
while not q dot empty
so basically as long as there are
elements that are not scanned in the
queue as long as the queue is not
empty what i'm going to do is i'm going
to say
port equals q dot get so i'm going to
get
the next port in the list since it's not
empty i'm going to get one
and then i'm going to say if port scan
of this port returns true
i'm going to print port
whatever is open
and we're going to say format port
and additionally we're going to add the
port to the open ports list so we're
going to say open ports dot append
port so we're adding our port to the
open ports list so that we can have
a good final report in the end now
otherwise if you want you can also print
port whatever is closed but when we run
that many threads
it will be very very hard to find the
open ports because we'll have a lot of
statements
at the same time so i think it's more
beneficial to just print the open port
just so we get a better overview of this
so we're going to delete this and we're
only going to print something
if the port scan returns true otherwise
we're not going to do anything
so these are the functions that we're
going to use now what we need to do is
first of all we need to fill
our queue and we can do whatever we want
you can say
i want all the ports from 0 to 5 000
or i want only 22 80 443 and so on
only the important ports that i'm
interested in just to find your own list
if you want i'm going to say
a port list equals range
1 up until 124
and now i'm going to say fill queue
port list
so the next step is to define a an empty
thread list and i'm going to explain in
a second why we need a list for our
threads because
actually to run the threads we don't
need this list but
we're going to need this list later on
because otherwise the last part of this
script is not going to work so
first of all we're going to say 40
in range and now we're going to specify
the number of
threads that we go uh we want to run so
do you want to run
10 threads do you want to run 20 threads
100 threads whatever
so let's start with 10 threads so
range 10 and now we're going to say
threat
equals threading dot thread with a
capital t
and we're going to say target
equals target
equals worker notice that we're not
calling the worker function here so
we're not saying worker in parentheses
we're just saying worker so we're
referring to the worker function
without actually calling it now what
we're doing here is we're creating
10 so range 10. so 10 times we're
creating a new
thread with the worker as the target
function
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say thread
threadless dot append thread
and then we have all these threads that
we created right now
in our list now the next step is to run
all of these
so we can save for thread in thread list
thread dot start
and last but not least this is the
important part why we need the list
we're going to wait for all threads to
finish so we're going to say
for thread in thread list
thread dot join the join method
waits until the thread is done until it
continues with the code so
after this statement here we're going to
print
the open ports open ports are
and open ports and the reason we have to
join here is because we don't want this
to get
printed until all the threads
are done so we only want to print all
the ports that are open in the end
when every thread is finished so
basically that's it now let's run this
when we run this you will see
that
we're going to make progress quite fast
so we already reached 22.25
and it scan basically scans 10 ports per
second more or less we have 10 times the
speed that we had
in the beginning so as you can see we
already reached port 80
but it's still not the fastest so if we
want to have this even faster we just
don't say 10 but we can say a hundred
and then it will
already scan 100 ports so we already
scan port 80
143 and so on and it's way faster and we
can't keep
increasing the number as long as it
seems to be faster because you know
sometimes or at some point you you will
reach a limit
and your computer is not going to
execute faster
but you can try with 500 for example and
you will immediately reach
500 as you can see so it's
quite fast i think when you say a
million it's not
uh it will not be faster but
as you can see with 500 it works quite
well
these are the open ports actually quite
a few
and i'm going to have to take care of
that because
obviously a lot of ports are open in my
router
we're going to develop a tcp chat in
python so we're going to set up a server
and we're going to set up multiple
clients and these clients can then
connect to the server
which works as a chat room you could say
and each client can then send messages
to the server with his or her nickname
and all the other clients can see these
messages and respond so let us get into
the code
now the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create a server file so
we're going to right click onto the
directory and create a server.py
file and in here we're going to import
threading
import threading and import sockets
these are the two modules that we're
going to
need in this video and if you don't know
how to work with sockets or you don't
know what sockets are you don't know
what
multi-threading is i highly recommend
that you check out the python
intermediate tutorial series on this
channel
because there i talk about network
programming about multi-threading what
these things are i also have a tutorial
on how to make
a port scanner a multi-threaded port
scanner where i use both concepts so
check out these videos
uh because i'm not going to go too much
into the details of threading or sockets
in this video
now the first thing we need to do here
is we need to define a host address and
a port for our server so
the host in this case will be just uh
127.0.0.1 because we're using
localhost so let's add a comment here
localhost
this is just because we are running this
on our machine if you run the server on
a web server you should always uh pick
the host address of the server so always
the ip address of the server
uh this is just the basic localhost
since we're running it on this computer
it uh will be localhost then we need a
port and as a port you can choose
whatever you want you could just go with
99872 or something like that
what you shouldn't do is you shouldn't
take ports like 80 because this is
http you should just not pick any
reserve ports or well-known ports at all
so
uh just don't choose any ports from one
to
i don't know i think 10 000 or something
but
we're just going to go with 55 555.
this is a solid port um and then what we
need to do is we need to start service
so we're going to say server equals
socket and in here we're going to say
it's an internet socket so socket dot
af inet and
then we're going to say it's uh
socket.stream so again if you don't know
what that means
uh oh sorry socket dot
suck stream if you don't know what that
is and if you don't know uh why we're
creating a socket in that way check out
the intermediate tutorial series they
will talk about
these concepts so next thing is we need
to bind the server to
the host and the ip address so we say
server.bind and we pass a tuple of host
and port so we're saying okay the server
is bound to the localhost on port
five five five five five five i think
this was five times fives hopefully uh
then we say
server.listen which basically puts our
server into listening mode
for a new connection so as soon as we
say server.listen the server starts
listening for
incoming connections now what we're
going to do next is we're going to
define a couple of methods we're going
to define three methods the first one
being a broadcast method
the second one being a handle method for
client connections and the last one
being a receive
method which basically combines all the
methods into a main method you could say
but before we do that we're going to
define two empty lists here and these
two empty lists
are the clients list and the nicknames
list
so these two lists will be the list
where we put all of our clients in so
if we have a new client connecting to
the server we're going to put it into
the clients list
and also we're going to get the nickname
of this client which the client can
then later on choose and we're going to
say okay the client
x has the nickname uh i don't know bob
or something like that
and then we can just use clients and
nicknames to
do certain things later on now the first
function we're going to define here is
the broadcast function is a very simple
function it's just a function that
sends a message to all the clients that
are currently connected
to this server so i'm going to say def
broadcast
and we're going to pass a message here
so we're going to say broadcast
message and then we're just going to
save for every client
in the clients list which now is empty
but later on we're going to fill it up
for every client that is now connected
to the server we're just going to say
dot sent this message
very simple we're just getting all the
clients and sending a particular message
and this is how you broadcast messages
from a server to all the clients so the
next thing that we want to do is we want
to handle the client connection so when
a client connects to the server
we want to receive messages from the
client if the client is sending any
and then we also want to uh send back
messages to all the other clients
depending on what the client sends so if
client a says
hi we want to get this message process
it and then
broadcast it to all the other clients
including uh
also client a itself because every
client needs to see what's happening in
the server
so what we want to do is want to find a
handle function and we want to handle
one particular client so we're we're
going to later on
run this function on all of the
individual clients but for now we're
just handling one
uh single client so we're getting the
client and what we do is we say
while true basically we're starting an
endless loop here
we're saying try a certain thing so as
long as it works without giving you an
exception or an error we're going to
just say message
equals client.receive
i think it's like that our ecv uh
1024 bytes just
the basic method uh message so what we
do here is we say okay as long as it
works
that we receive a message from the
client we're just going to broadcast it
to all the other uh clients
or oh sorry no uh broadcast a message to
all the other clients
so what we're doing here is we say try
to receive a message from the client
and if that succeeds broadcast this
message to all the other clients
including this client as well if that
doesn't work
so if we get some exception some error
while receiving the message
or while broadcasting what we're going
to do is we're going to just uh
cut the connection to this particular
client remove it from the list and then
uh
basically terminate this function so
we're going to say or terminate this
loop
so we're going to say the index of this
particular client
is the clients.index of this client and
we need this index in order to remove
the nickname and the client from the
list
so we're just getting the index okay
where is this particular client that
failed right now in the list which index
does it have
and then we're going to say
clients.remove
client so we're going to just remove the
client we're going to close the
connection to the client
and then we're also going to say okay
the nickname of this client
is the nicknames
index of the client so basically
whenever we're adding a client we're
also adding the nickname so they will
always have the same index
and when we remove a client we also
remove the nickname on this particular
index so that we don't get any
inconsistencies here
so what we do then is we say nicknames
dot
remove our nickname
and you could either print it before
that i'm going to print it before that
or you can print it afterwards we're
just going to broadcast to all the
clients that this client has now left so
we're going to say
broadcast and we're going to use an f
string here
and we're going to say nickname
left the chat for example
um and then we're going to encode this
message
in ascii code
so that we get the right message
so after that of course we're breaking
out of the loop and that's
it so we're handling a client one client
connects and what we're doing is we're
constantly trying to get messages from
this client
uh this will not give you an error if
the client is not sending anything but
it will give you an error if this client
is not there anymore so
as soon as a client produces some kind
of error what we do is we just remove it
from the list remove the nickname
and broadcast to all the different uh
clients connected to the server that
this client is now left
and then we just terminate this function
so this function will later on run in a
thread
for each client we'll have a single
thread running and
processing this particular function or
actually executing the handle function
and as soon as a client disconnects what
we do is we just break this
loop and therefore terminate the
function therefore terminate or
end the threat so this is how we're
going to handle the client
connection so now last but not least in
the server what we're going to do is
we're going to define the main method
the receive method which
combines all these things that we've
written up until now into one function
so we're going to say
def receive and we're going to just
receive client connection so we're
saying
while true what the server is doing it
is basically accepting
all the connections so we're going to
say client
and address equals server.accept so
what's happening is we're running the
accept method
all the time and if this method gets a
connection
what we get what it returns is a client
and the address of the client so in this
case we're always going to have the same
address since we're on one computer but
if you have this running on a server
you'll see the address the ip address
of this client connecting to your server
so
basically we're connecting to clients or
allowing the clients to connect
and if this is done if this happens if a
client connects we're just going to say
print on the server itself this is not a
broadcast this is just on the server
console so that we see what's happening
um connected
with and let's make an f string out of
this
connected with address
so that we know actually we should say
str address
double d there you go so we're waiting
for a connection we're accepting all the
connections coming and if a connection
happens to come in fact come in this
moment
what we do is we just print that we now
connect it to this client
on this particular address and then of
course what we want to do is we want to
get the nickname of the client so the
client will be able
before it connects to our server to
choose a nickname and it will then
it will then be the nickname that is
displayed on the server
uh so what we need to do first is we
need to ask the client for
the nickname because of course if it
just sends us a message we're going to
process it
but the first message that the client
sends to us should be the nickname so
what we're going to say is we're going
to send a message
to this client and this message will be
a code word which is not visible to the
user of the client it's just visible to
the client
itself later on in the code we're going
to send the keyword
nick and if the client receives this
keyword nick
it should be um it should be informed
that it should send the nickname to the
server so that the server knows who
are you we're going to say encode
ascii again and we're basically just
sending this keyword and in the next
step what we hope to receive from the
client
is the nickname itself so we're going to
say
client dot receive
and we're going to receive 1024
bytes and decode them from
ascii so
then of course what we're going to do is
we're going to say nicknames
dot append nickname
and clients dot append
client and then what we need to do is we
just need to send a couple of messages
here so we're going to say okay
print nickname of the client is okay
so there you go nickname of the client
is and then nickname of the k9
of the client just connected is whatever
and then we're just going to broadcast
that so that everyone every client
is currently connected to the server
knows that this client is now connected
and that's the nickname of this client
so we're just going to say
f string
nickname joined the
chat and we're going to encode this
message
again and then every server
sorry every client knows that there is a
new client in this chat
and they get a message that this client
just joined the chat with the
respective nickname and then we're going
to send the particular client that just
connected we're going to send to the one
client
that uh this client connected to the
server so we're going to say sent
uh connect it to the
server so that the client knows that
it's now connected and it can start
chatting and of course we're going to
encode this message
as well now we're almost done the last
two things that we're going to do is
we're going to define a thread and run a
thread so we're going to say
threat as we said we're going to run one
thread for each client
connected because we need to handle them
at the same time we cannot
just handle them serially because uh one
client might send something and another
client might send something and we need
to process it
at the same time or at least uh roughly
at the same time and not just
you know process one client interaction
then start
with the next one so what we're going to
do is we're going to say threading
dot threat capital t
and the target of this thread will be
the handle function
and the arguments will be just
client and then we're going to say
thread dot start and
if you know about if you know how to
deal with python threads you know that
you need to use the start method and not
to run method because otherwise this
doesn't work
so let's uh look one more time at this
code what we're doing is we're just
saying
accept clients all the time when a
client actually connects we're going to
just say
okay connected with this client so that
the server admin knows what's happening
then we're going to send to the client
the keyword nick or the code word nick
so that the client knows okay i need to
send my nickname
we're then going to receive the nickname
from the client append this nickname and
this client to
our lists and then we're going to print
on the server again for the server admin
that the nickname of this client is
whatever
then we're going to broadcast to all the
clients connected to the server that
this client with this nickname
now join the chat we're going to send a
message to the particular client that
the connection was successful
and then we're going to start a thread
handling the connection to this
particular client
so now we can actually start coding the
client but before we do that i need to
add one more line here the receive
method also needs to be called because
we defined all this but we didn't run it
so
the received method is our main method
and it runs down here
uh we could actually also go ahead and
run the server but you're not going to
see anything
but a good sign is that it's running and
not crashing so it probably works
but for the server to do something of
course we need a client to connect to it
because otherwise it's not going to do
anything
what we could do is we could just print
out the message
server is listening listen
dot dot dot and then it
yeah you can see the server is listening
and that's how you run the server now
the next thing is we need to define the
client so we're going to say
client dot py and here also we're going
to import socket
and import threading
and we're also going to define a socket
so we're going to say client
equals socket dot
socket af oh sorry socket dot
af by net
and socket dot sock stream
there you go and now instead of binding
the client to
our a port and a host we're going to
connect it to a
host on the port so we're going to say
client.connect
and we're going to connect it to
localhost so
127.0.0.1
and we're going to connect it on port
5555
and now we're connecting it to the
server so in this line when this line
gets
executed the server will receive uh will
trigger the accept method and the client
is now connected to the server
so what we're going to do in this client
is we're going to define two methods and
run
two threads simultaneously so we're
going to receive all the time
data from the server so we're going to
have a receive function that's running
constantly
and at the same time we're going to um
to send messages or we need a thread
running for all the messages that we're
going to send
so let's start with the receiving part
define a function receive
and this function is just running again
in a while true loop
and we're going to try something all the
time what we're going to try is we're
going to receive messages
from the server so in this case uh we'll
say
client.receive but the client is
actually receiving from the server so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say message equals client.receive just
don't get confused
we're still receiving from the server
not from the client but
uh for the server to send messages it
uses a client so
it could be considered a client so we're
receiving
1024 bytes and we're decoding what we
receive
and that's basically it now what we need
to do is we need to check
if the message that we just received is
nick or something else so we're going to
say okay if message
equals nick which is the key word for
sending the nickname
we're going to send the nickname i'm
just going to pass here because we need
to
get the nickname first in the beginning
of the script and if it's not nickname
what we're going to do is we're just
going to print the message so whenever
we get a message from the server
that's not nik or any other keyword that
we define we're just going to print the
message
because we're not going to do anything
about it we just want to see what the
server
has to tell us so we're going to say
message print or
print message if that doesn't work what
we're going to do
is we're just going to close the
connection so we're going to say
uh an error occurred
and i think double r i'm not sure
oh man i think it's misspelt yeah double
r
uh an error occurred and uh then we're
just going to close the connection
so we're going to say client close and
we're going to
break this endless loop
now how are we going to send the
nickname first of all we need the
nickname so we're going to say nickname
equals input choose
a nickname so whenever we run a client
the first thing that we want to do is we
want to choose a nickname
and if the message equals nick what
we're going to do is we're going to say
client dot send
and we're going to send the nickname the
encoded version
to the server so what's happening here
is the server is listening all the time
the client is choosing a nickname
connects to the server
and the moment this happens this gets
triggered we say connected with whomever
and the first thing that the server then
does is it sends the keyword nic so
we're going to get the keyword nick
we're going to send the client name or
the nickname
then we're going to receive it here
append it and whatever and then we're
having a connection
and as soon as the server sends
something to us we're going to receive
it and print it
onto our screen now let's finish off the
client by defining the second function
which
is the write function and what this
function does
is it runs a while loop as well
in endless loop and here what we do is
we always define a new message so we're
going to say message
equals um f string and here we're going
to say
nickname colon and then the actual
message the actual message
is always what the user puts into the
script so
oh i need to use double quotation marks
here um what we're doing here is we're
constantly running new input functions
so as soon as the user clicks enter and
sends one input we ask for the next one
so the user
the only option that the user has is to
either close the client or
write new messages so we are always
waiting for new messages this is a
threat
receive and write will run
simultaneously and the right function is
always waiting for a new message
and you send a message by clicking the
enter key and once you get a message so
once you click enter or press
enter what happens is you say client dot
sent
and we're sending the message of course
encoded
and that's basically it that's the whole
function
and now what we need to do is we need to
run two threads we need to run a receipt
thread and a right thread so we're going
to say receive
thread equals threading
dot thread with the target function
of receive we don't need any arguments
here
and then we're going to say receive
thread dot
start and then we're going to do the
same thing for the writing thread so
right thread
equals threading dot threat and a target
here
is the write function and we're going to
start this thread as well
and now we're done with that but
uh the problem here is that in pycharm
we can only run
one client at a time and to see how this
works we need to run one server
and two clients so i'm going to run this
in a command line right now
so right here i navigated three
terminals into the direction of the tcp
chat and what i'm going to do on the
left side here this will be a server
and these two right terminals here are
going to be um
the clients so i'm going to just say
python
server dot py and as you can see server
is listening
and here we're just going to say python
client
and we can choose a nickname so for
example let's say neural nine
is a nickname and as you can see we get
connected with
the ip address and the port nickname of
the client is neural nine
i can see here on the right neural nine
jointer chat because this is a broadcast
message that gets sent
to all the clients including myself
and also connected to the server and now
we can run a second client so we say
python
client.py
and i can choose a nickname here let's
say youtube
audience so you guys and you can see i
get here again connected nickname
is youtube audience here i see youtube
audience joined to chat connected to
server and here on neural nine i can see
uh youtube audience joined the chat so i
can say
hi or hey youtube
then what happens here in the server i
don't see anything because the server is
just monitoring the connections
and here on the client side i see hey
youtube from myself
but also the youtube audience here sees
hey
youtube from neural nine so it can
answer hey
what's up and i can also see it up here
and i can also start spamming here if i
want and
you'll see it in both uh clients so this
is how you do
a professional advanced chat of course
you could also add some
special commands like kik or ban or
i don't know emojis or something but
this is a basic version of a
chat room